you
I began the work that ultimately led to
the sliding filament theory of muscle
contraction in 1950 I was a research
student in a small MRC unit with John
Kendrew as my supervisor and Max Perutz
being the head of the unit and that was
it it was just three people I had been a
student in physics and my main interest
had been in experimental particle
physics but after graduation I decided
to change field completely during this
unit and was in fact in complete freedom
to choose my own particular subject of
research during the first couple of
years I spent doing some work on
hemoglobin and learning a bit of biology
of which I was totally ignorant
originally and then I chose muscle as a
possible topic because I'd found that
although a lot of luck was known about
the mechanics and energetics and
biochemistry of muscle virtually nothing
was known about its submicroscopic
structure nor about what actually
happened during contraction now one way
of getting that information might be
that if muscle was composed of regular
repeating or semi crystalline units of
these two structural proteins then one
might get evidence about what was
happening from x-ray diffraction however
people have looked at wide-angle x-ray
diffraction which showed you any changes
in the polypeptide chain configuration
and essentially if you didn't show
anything and it also looked at dried
muscle by low angle diffraction which
showed you
structural regularities and size of
protein molecules but that hadn't been
informative either
however I'd learned that one had to keep
protein crystals fully hydrated if you
were going to get anything useful in an
x-ray diagram from them so I thought
well maybe that would be true of muscle
and maybe muscle really did contain lots
of regular structures if anyone could
attack it the right way and so for that
purpose I built a miniaturized x-ray
camera which would optimize the the
sensitivity of images collected on film
and it's also very fortunate that my
supervisor John Kendrew knew a man
called banal in London who in whose
x-ray group two people were actually
building a very fine focus
high-intensity x-ray generator x-ray
tube for another purpose and they were
kind enough to give me an early
prototype of this which formed an
essential part of the x-ray setup that I
built I was very thrilled and relieved
to see that I did in fact get quite a
well-defined x-ray diagram not not very
detailed but it consisted basically of
two two reflections one here and then
another one a bit further out and the
spacing of these told one they came from
a hexagonal arrangement of objects and I
concluded that this must be an octagonal
arrangement of myosin filaments but what
was particularly interesting was that in
a muscle in Riga the pattern had the
same spacing that approximately but the
relative intensity of the two spots had
had changed and this told one that there
was some alteration in the character of
the lattice and that in fact you can
projection of the electron density from
those diagrams this is a myosin filament
here on my picture and then this is
another myosin filament there and
another one in the lattice over here in
between the myosin filaments is what I
took to be actin filaments which
appeared at low density in the relaxed
muscle but in rygg or muscle their
density was much increased now I knew
that actin and myosin tended to combine
with others in the absence of ATP that's
in a rag or muscle so I concluded and
turned out I was correct that that was
in fact what I was seeing a double array
of actin and myosin filaments
interpenetrating with each other
I could also see some reflections axial
reflections which give you information
about the longitudinal regularities
along the length of the muscle this is
spacing of about 145 angstroms and there
are another series reflections not shown
here the interesting so it showed that
the muscle was a sort of semi
crystalline structure at this scale and
these reflections didn't change in
spacing when the muscle was passively
stretched now I made a mistake at that
point I thought that these probably
these reflections probably all came from
the actin filaments so I concluded the
actin filaments didn't change in length
but I still had this picture that
perhaps the myosin filaments somehow
others shortened down anyway I finished
my PhD and went to MIT to Swift lab
which was a scent of a new center for
doing electron microscope work because I
wanted to make sure that these this
double array of filaments really existed
so by fixing embedding and section
muscle I was able to look at
cross-sections in the electron
microscope and lo and behold one could
see the double array of filaments very
very clearly this was this was a rabbit
muscle in Riga this is a myosin filament
and that that's another myosin filament
then the actin filaments are in this
little ring of six of them around each
myosin Center so that that was very
encouraging and then shortly after this
early in 1953 gene Hanson came to the
same lab to learn electric microscopy -
because she'd been studying isolated
myofibrils as seen in the light
microscope but she was a zoologist by
training and we decided we were both
doing the same thing essentially we
decided to combine our different
approaches and this worked out very
successfully one of the first
experiments we did was to look at my
fibrils in the light microscope on the
covers on a slide with the coverslip
over them in the phase contrast
microscope and you get very nice images
of the a and I bends
I'll show you one in a moment and when
we irrigated these with solutions known
to extract myosin from muscle we found
that the dense material in the a band
here was rapidly removed leaving a sort
of ghost fiber which consisted of the
original Z lines and a segment of
filament which we concluded and we're
probably acting and we later found that
applying actin extraction procedures
would remove this second set of
filaments as well these are just showing
the density plots before and after
myosin extract
so this was sort of quite a
revolutionary finding for us and but
after a few hours we'd sort of
reoriented our way of thinking about
things and we realized that we were
looking at two Oh
partially interpenetrating but
overlapping arrays of myosin filaments
and actin filaments and that the
cross-sections I'd seen had been through
the overlap region here and so that this
is what I showed before the overlap
region in the H zone which where the
actin filaments have stopped you just
see the thick filaments and in the eye
bands you can see the cross sections of
the thin filaments so we we then had a
quite new model of the structure of the
muscle and in between the two sets of
filaments were these cross bridges that
I'd have postulated must be there to
enable the two sets of the actin and
myosin filaments to interact with each
other so we published the short paper on
this in nature but at Smith's request we
emitted any speculation about the Herot
and how this system would actually work
but what we knew was that there were
these two types of these two axial
series of x-ray reflections which didn't
change during passive stretch and so we
thought well maybe they didn't change
you're in contraction either and that
would mean that the two sets of
filaments would themselves remain
constant in length and that contraction
would be achieved by the actin filaments
sliding further in to the array of
myosin filaments and when we after a lot
of hard work we were able to get
sufficient images of muscle at different
stages of contraction to prove that
point and you can see this is
a slightly stretched myofibril then we
give it a little bit of ATP and it
shortens down a little the I bands the
clearer regions become shorter that the
a bands stay constant in length and as
it shortens further still the I bands
get even shorter and ultimately that
they almost disappear if we can also
extract myosin from a stretched fibril
and we can see the large gap between the
ends of the actin filaments but when on
the course a different fibril which is
contracted we can see this gap between
the actin shortening down and then
disappearing so we can measure the
length of the I filaments and that was
constant during contraction so so this
was written up for nature and published
in late May in 1954 along with another
paper by Andrew Huxley's actually no
relation of mine and now neither gurkha
who had used special interference
microscope to look it's intact fibers
and they'd found the same thing insofar
as the a band stayed constant in length
but that their optics when such as to be
able to see they measure the length of
the actin filaments so that would so
that we thought was pretty strong
evidence for the this type of model but
it still remained quite controversial
for a number of years particularly
because I think some of the other
workers in the field hadn't thought of
got used to this combination of x-rays
in the M and Ferries microscopy but I
think it's a few more people were
probably convinced by some electron
micrographs that I was able to get two
or three years later which showed the
longer scheudle sections through the
myofibril through the muscle fiber in
which you can see the thick filaments
very clearly I think stopping at the end
of the a band whereas the thin filaments
continue on and into the I bands out
here and you can also at higher
magnification you can see these cross
bridges between the actin and myosin
filaments that I'd suppose must be able
to produce the relative sliding force
that produces contraction there's any
general conclusions about how you go
about a problem you can draw from this
well I'm not sure that there are urban
and I think I was very lucky because I
had a clearly defined problem and I was
able to find some new techniques which
provided a way into it so if you can
repeat that process you might get lucky
like I did thank you
you